what I think the organizers are PI data
it's a it's great to see these orange
t-shirts and all the people that are
making this a phenomenal I came here in
2013 one of the first pie data's none
folks has been dear to my heart from
2012 and we first started it and I
started talking with Leah about how do
we organize numb focus I really make it
a community centric event and an
organization and pi did has just
exploded throughout the world with
people like these fine people who it's a
community based community organization
and a lot of great things are happening
I've been part of this Python community
for a long time as they describe
definitely 1997 I'm a Python enthusiast
since 1987 is my slide show I've been
really anxious about figuring out how to
ensure that those who are using array or
in computing and Python can continue to
do that in an effective way as scalable
computing many core computing emerges on
the scene and that's been I've been
driving me for the past four years and
I'm pretty excited to talk about some of
the things we've been doing that have
actually come to fruition and you can
today do things that many people don't
realize it's possible so basically out
trying to convince and show people that
a lot of things are doing today can be
done better by using the tools that are
now available in the Python ecosystem
things like number things like task so
I'm talking about scale up versus scale
out and how do we scale up is the idea
of getting bigger boxes better computer
more memory more machine more cpus on
the computer scale-out is about getting
more computers and they have different
characteristics in terms of wanting to
do different kinds of problems with both
the software you have to write in order
to take advantage of each of these
scenarios is a little bit different and
of course the best of both worlds were
really after how do we actually have
clusters of very powerful machines for
the biggest problems so the Python side
of Eagle ecosystem it's actually a very
detailed story I guess I could spend two
hours sort of telling you about the
origins of this community it's very
interesting actually I've been fortunate
to be a part of it since 1997 and
watching all the different folks and
definitely one thing I could say that's
necessary for this to work his community
it is the PI data and the scientific
computing story in Python is about many
many people however it is also about
certain people who spend a lot of time
working the West McKinney put a lot of
effort in the pandas John Hunter palapa
from the matplotlib it is not true that
you just sort of throw the internet open
and
hope that occasional you know pull
requests emerge libraries that's not
really how it works what works is
somebody puts a lot of effort into
creating something and then people
gather around that thing and then make
it better and it's that and both of
those are necessary so I say that
because you may have an idea you may
have something you want to pull together
and you should you should go pursue it
go pursue something build it build a
kernel and then understand how it
interacts and connects with the wider
ecosystem in order to broaden the appeal
and get many people using it together so
this side of the ISA ecosystem like I
said I've spent the first 15 years of my
Python life effectively a developer and
a practitioner using this tool the start
as a scientist and that led me to build
CyHi that led me to make numpy so
unified the world's led me to kind of
write some books do some Python peps
internet become a Python core developer
a lot of time spent trying to make the
foundations this ecosystem compatible I
plan to spend the next 15 years of my
life basically ensuring that this
ecosystem can scale both up and out take
advantage of GPUs take advantage of
multi-core systems the new Intel five
machines making sure that they can take
advantage of clusters of machines and
and the same agile interactive
exploration made possible by the tools
in Python today continue to be possible
at scale and you can have huge systems
so this is a many-faceted effort a lot
about rallying community creating them
focus encouraging the PI data ecosystem
building anaconda as a distribution so
that everybody can get this stuff really
quickly and there's been a series of
technologies we've been pursuing a
continuum analytics to try to fill in
some gaps that we see I mean connoisseur
the basic python packaging solution if
you're not using anaconda or having
aren't fully taking advantage of Conda
environments and shared environments you
should take a look at an account of
cloud take a look at what's possible
because a lot is possible that I suspect
you're that many of you may not be aware
of today then of course numbered asked
dying blaze and a new thing data fabric
I'm not going to go into detail about
all this today I'm going to talk about
some of it but there's a lot more to do
in 2012 we took off it continuum and the
effort was to scale numpy numpy they
could make a next-generation numpy
that's what we said we wanted to do
that's what we started working on and
numba was the scale up and blaze the
scale out and those are the major
efforts
and in the process we started working
directly with numpy realized that that
needed to be a maintained library and it
was hard to innovate on it quickly
because just the status of its amateur
library in 9 2013 actually officially
retired from maintaining numpy
maintaining temp I'm still a big
advocate of numpy still know the code
really well I still understand exactly
how it's built but there's a fortunately
a very other group of people who are
helping maintain them by so I want to
make clear and I don't speak for a numpy
and where it's headed right I definitely
am I mean I'm just like any of you in
that regard i'm an individual have ideas
and then in order for numpy itself to
move that community of people are making
numpy move would move it forward my
efforts are not so much a single library
but a collection of capabilities with an
emphasis on scale and it's definitely a
community effort I'm going to speak
today about a work I don't do this work
all myself going to speak about work
that's been done by continuing primarily
people that continuum some great
developers who have joined me enjoying
my co-founder Peter at continuum in
order to produce these technologies so
so I'm not gonna be a tough time there
detail to go through all their names and
show other pictures I would at some
future point but recognize that it's a
big community beyond what we're doing a
continuum of course the entire ecosystem
around Python perdida science is also
growing it's evidenced here but all the
people here in the talks here there's a
lot of things happening and it's very
exciting to see and that was actually
one of the intentional things then we
started in 2012 we did we organized a
pie to that event at googolplex in 2012
that's actually where the original Conda
came from when we'd have said they have
to write your own package manager
because I don't care and so we did right
we took him at his word and then but PI
data has grown its when in 2012 is when
I managed to find Leah put her is the
executive director of Nome focus
organized um focus with fernando and
john hunter and david perry excuse me
Perry greenfield and Jared Millman and
that organization is now taking off I
just advise it now and I don't spend a
whole lot of time so but I love to see
the growth that it's taking place in
that organization and around the world
as the Pied of the community has come
together that's very very exciting num
focus is basically patchy for open a to
science you had a great introduction
from James Powell there about it James
has been quite in a super volunteer i
would say in an unfocused invited
ecosystem he's sort of been there all
the time and really helping like it's
amazing the guy doesn't sleep or he
doesn't I don't know what he does but
it's amazing all the things he does to
try to grow the community and to try to
make sure that these kind of events can
take place of course I needed to go
organize a company as well I actually
have six children they are getting more
expensive every day and three in college
today and as much as I love to spend all
my days ha keynote open source software
I still actually have to get paid
somehow my wife seeps keeps wondering
when I'm actually to bring home any
money so I I kept types to know it's
going to work somehow sweetheart
eventually believe me somebody will pay
me eventually so we have to work we have
to create a company and I'm actually a
big believer in markets I actually
believe companies are a key way that you
give people what they need and there's
different needs there's different
desires from a community-based what
communities going to build and what a
company can build to ensure that the
open source software works well at scale
in production and a company works with
their integrates with their security
systems and all those things our purpose
of continuum is to empower people to
solve the world's greatest challenges it
is and and that is definitely we take
that seriously and i love it when i see
the tools that I've been working on for
years show up in the to find
gravitational waves Kent that was a very
amazing thing this past year I felt very
very proud that people were that scifi
signal was involved in finding some of
those tools sci-fi signal is the very
first module extension module i wrote
for Syfy as a grad student at the mayo
clinic so it's very excited to see that
as we help people discover analyze and
collaborate by connecting curiosity and
their experience with any data it's a
broad goal that we're accomplishing that
with a number of friends we start
working on key technologies with a lot
of help from X data the DARPA funded
program to help us in order for us to
work on technology we got to have
funding from somewhere some of that
funding comes from our profits from
consulting and by companies funding it
directly some of that comes from X data
or other governmental agencies given us
grants in order to prakan this and we
hope that someday someone will come from
profits from product sales but that's
still a work in progress and we're still
hoping that will happen start with the
key technologies were building are
things like blaze bouquet numba blaze
basically was a was a
big project big problem and it factored
off a ton of activity and now I'm going
to talk today about how desk is emerging
as the way to do parallel numpy and
pandas tile computing which is extremely
exciting create a platform anaconda is
free and open-source just go click on it
download and get everything you need in
one easy install it's an open data
science platform powered by Python
fastest growing open data science
language it does a lot of things to help
you get insights from data more quickly
and more robustly and faster this is the
obligatory market texture diagram it
just illustrates anaconda is intended to
be full-featured to basically be a
solution for DevOps date engineers
developers data scientist and business
analyst bringing them all together and
work together as a team to work on top
of all the data all the libraries and
integrate governance provenance and
security issues the free foundation
provides a huge amount of this and then
we have some subscriptions on top that
deliver the rest for a company one thing
I want to make clear and once you
understand that free anaconda now has a
very interesting feature in which it
comes with MK libraries by default so
the Intel MK libraries now some of you
may know the anacondas BSD that means
you can take it include it in your stuff
redistribute it you don't have get
permission and that includes the MK
libraries that are now included with MK
out with with anaconda so this is the
easiest way to actually get anaconda and
redistribute application with MKL
attached we have special permission from
Intel to do this so it's a great way to
get fast performant libraries and
connect them to your application and
spend since version 2.5 which is
released in january of this year and
these provide optimal performance for sy
pi/4 num exper and for numpy on the
linear algebra tools I also wanted to
make sure and think and encourage people
to check out Conda forge Kanta forges
amazing community lead Conda package
channel so if you haven't if you're not
familiar with the Conda packager Conda
is a package manager for OS 10 mac and
linux that gives you the ability to
create new environments easily with all
the dependencies you need for the
software you're distributing and running
and playing with so gone are the days
where you have to spend hours and years
to kind of build your patio python
environment then panic when it
disappears I I delete and remove con
environments all the time
because I can quickly get back to them
and so kind of Forge it's a
community-led builder of condo packages
they have some automated tools to build
and test recipes it's extremely awesome
you basically can add you can install
packages from there using the dash see
Conda Forge you saw a few people showing
you that into in today's demos really
what the intent is to make sure that no
demo at PI data is not reproducible
everybody gives a demo if they have kind
of package what they're doing can
instantly provide you with an
environment with everything you need to
make that demo work no matter who you
are but it isn't well here's the code
hopefully your compiler works and it
works in your system no it's here's the
binaries it can work every time easily
reproducibly you can add the channel
kind of force your config now every time
you can't install it's going to look for
on that channel for packages as well it
is community-led one of the differences
between the Anaconda channel from
continuum is basically it's our tested
channel we are definitely working in
concert with that community channel we'd
love to eventually have all of the
Anaconda package basically be just a
tested set of the community packages and
have the community package be a very
very rapid place where things can emerge
very very quickly that's my ideal in
2012 at PI data in New York City we
promised that we're going to work on
parallel pandas and parallel numpy
that's what we were working on and some
people mistook our enthusiasm for hey we
got something working already that was
not the intent it was a developer
conference where I was like hey we're
working on some things who wants to join
us and that was the whole intent to
describe it i'm here today to talk we
have some stuff working and it's really
cool you got to use it so it's different
today and but we introduced them early
we're now ready to rally a user
community around these tools because
it's absolutely ready for prime time so
the eagle has landed and milestones
success in 2016 numba is delivering on
scale out on scale a scale scale up
actually I've got these backwards oh how
embarrassing numba is delivering on
scale up and ask is delivering on scale
out and that's happening today so it's
very exciting and I'll you'll I know
that numbers familiar to some you learn
more about it from Graham later and ask
is familiar probably just a few and
we'll talk more about that today to give
it a little preview of what's possible
if you combine number and asks you get
the best of all
world scaled up scaled out you have
clusters of fast machines able to do
amazing things like sub-second rendering
of three billion points in a browser
backed by big enough machines to do it
so this is OpenStreetMap data connected
with something called the data shader
which is an open source package
connected with the bouquet project that
lets you just take extremely large data
and look at it and look at it in a
visually perceptual accurate way that
avoids some of the over sampling and the
and the binning problems that occur if
you just put a scatter plot in
matplotlib or something for billions of
points it's an exciting innovation made
possible by the combination of Basque
and number so it's a great example of
kind of pulling these together in order
to produce amazing solutions quickly
just another example of data shader
working now on the census data with
categorical data showing up as colors
you can do this for kind of any kind of
data set show it easily on a map but do
the computation necessary to do the
aggregations quickly at scale and to
just just basically to show you that as
possible now the other thing I'm excited
about and I'm just going to touch on it
barely and briefly if you're interested
in understanding this more come talk to
us come talk to me I can help you
understand how you today can take
advantage of numba and ask inside of
your Hadoop ecosystem your new cluster
when I first started in 2012 one of the
reasons we start a continuum was to
solve this problem of an ecosystem that
was adopting Hadoop rapidly with what I
consider to be substandard execution
environments and certainly MapReduce was
way substandard sparkers come along and
improve that situation but I think it's
still not what is possible for the
Python ecosystem and so we are happy
that we we've always been able to with
anaconda connect through and use spark
and talk to spark there's lots of people
here using pi spark and leveraging our
and Python with spark that's kind of
anaconda beside Hadoop that's kind of
anaconda outside and you can do graphs
you can do boquete visualizations you
can do matlab and every other thing
outside of it what's exciting today is
we can actually talk directly to HDFS
HDFS data without the JVM so get rid of
the JVM have your data in Hadoop talk to
it do it through HDFS use scheduled
resources with yarn but now your
execution is all done with Python all
with anaconda and then the whole breadth
of parallel ecosystem is available to
you ipython parallel
mpi tools everything of course basque is
now available as well so you can do the
same kind of thing you're used to but
now with anaconda and our early results
show I mean it can be it depends on what
you're doing is whether it's faster or
not and it can be you know basically the
same speed if you're not really using
leveraging the native machine code that
is made possible by leveraging our conv
but if you are doing an array computing
linear algebra kinds of operations you
can get ten to a hundred times faster
than spark than PI spark and you can
interact the data nav natively
distributed computations without JVM
without serialization without some of
the trouble that happens with having to
have JVM memory and python memory and
figure out which way which one is which
very exciting stuff that's one of these
I'm here as I really want to make sure
people understand that this is possible
today and it's open source and the tools
work together now somebody asked what
happened to blaze well still going
strong actually it's just refocused in a
different place in the stack it's
sometimes the description of ecosystem
as well so I'm going to start by telling
you exactly where blaze fits and will
run through this pretty quickly because
I don't have a lot of time the point of
blaze is to is to allow the separation
of expressions metadata and runtime so
expressions are the kinds of operations
you want to do and today the challenge
exists if you want to do a data science
the first question you have to ask
yourself is where is my data to give its
in a sequel database or fits in Hadoop /
if it's in a bunch of flat files the
code you write is quite different it's
quite different that's unfortunate it's
like we're back in the 60s for
assistance programmers if you like to
write different kinds of machine code
because there wasn't a single way to
express computing and of course Fortran
and C fixed that Blaze's a layer on top
similar to what sequel tries just trying
to do but allowing for advanced
analytics we're sequels not quite enough
so blazed gives you the ability to write
high-level expressions than it back ends
two different backgrounds so I'm going
to talk more about dascon numba and how
those backends are enabling Python to be
a first-class citizen in the otherwise
JVM dominated scale out solutions story
but blaze can talk to spark ladies can
talk to Impala blades can talk to
whatever database solution solution you
choose and it relies on something called
data shape I'm going to skate I'm going
to skip through these quickly so I can
talk more about some of the other tools
but I want to mention that data shape is
an important data declaration innovation
dying which will he can hear about from
Irwin he'll speak later just after this
session I believe definitely encouraged
to go listen to him uses this as a
low-level description of data it's a
generalization of the numpy d-type but
allows for all kinds of data structure a
raise the structures the kinds of data
that is common and then there's a blade
server component and then the blaze
client so basically the blaze allows you
to talk right your expressions and have
an arbitrary back-end compute them it's
still a work in progress so I'm not here
to announce the blaze is ready for prime
time jump on board if you're interested
in blaze I'm during a student having you
work out with blaze but come talk with
somebody who's using blaze it requires
still a little bit of hand-holding to
make it work right for you the other
projects i'm going to talk about numba
and ask are ready for you to try out
ready they still are open source
projects ready for contributors ready
for bug reports but they're definitely
ready for use data fabric this is more
in the line of alpha demo where hey it's
the newest thing if you're interested
working on this come talk to me I'm very
excited about this this to me is the
culmination of the effort i started in
1998 with Syfy it's trying to make a
system that allows all kinds of
languages to adapt to all kinds of data
leveraging data shape and we've been
working on some of the foundations here
they give you a brief overview of numba
if you want more go talk to ghosts go
see graham Markel's talk i'm gonna go
rapidly go through these slides so you
can just get a taste of what's possible
if you're not familiar and I'll slow
down a little bit as I go through a
particular demo that I want to make sure
you understand them so numbers very easy
to use you put a jit decorator around
your code and assuming that it can
understand all the types in your code
and all those types are arrays or
scalars and not crazy things like
dictionaries of sets of arbitrary
objects then it will speed that up and
write native machine code out of it and
if you do that then you get incredible
speed ups speedups including GPU
speedups of 2000 x now you look at those
who go holy cow 2000 x yes you can
absolutely take your Python code and
make it 2,000 x faster definitely seen
that in practice seen that in production
in some cases if you've written your
Python code particularly badly which is
unfortunately more common than not you
can actually get a hundred thousand XP
code
so we have cases where that's been been
true so I can't say that all of that is
because of our optimizations though it's
just because of people not writing very
good Python to begin with so how does a
number work it takes your code know how
easy it was just a jit on top of your
code well how does that work well it
actually waits to compile it until it
gets called because at that point it
knows what you're calling it with and
all the type information can be can flow
through and the lowering can take place
it's doesn't require a C C++ compiler it
is a compiler does it replace standard
Python interpreter unlike some other
approaches so it's uses all your
libraries and it's ready to play
alongside with an umpire than the plight
of the stack the typical way to use it
is to a hotspot profile so really to use
number effectively got to be good at
profiling find the place of your code is
wrong or not wrong but slow and try to
make it faster with numba jit or number
of vectorize i'm going to skip this one
which is filtering array shows you how
you can be faster than numpy by 22.7
just by even more sometimes 9x I'm going
to skip it so I can focus my attention
on number around the number of vectorize
concept and show you and this is an
underappreciated concept I think inside
of numpy is a powerful abstraction
called a you funk who knows what you
funks and generalize you from sir let me
say that actually you know that
generalize you funk is there have you
know what if generalize you funk is ok
that's what I thought about three people
right that's unfortunate because
generalize you funks basically when used
correctly can reproduce all of numpy or
most of numpy that's a hypothesis not a
proof statement so but you can certainly
reproduce astana stuff from somebody who
wrote a lot of nos I pie especially a
lot you know sci fi as it was in 2001
and somebody who wrote a lot of numb
pires it was in 2006 all of that i would
say ninety percent of that could have
been replicated with what the techniques
i'm going to show you right now so that
means you can unlock the inner secrets
of dumb pi by using numpy vector numba
vectorize and by understanding the
concept of generalized you funk a
generalize you funk is an abstraction
let's start with you farm you funk is a
cart you write a kernel that takes
scalar inputs or return scalar outputs
and then you apply that Colonel to all
the elements of an array very
straightforward it's like a map but that
kernel is now compiled code so it's the
same thing you do like in parent
as you know that a pan is applying you
apply a kernel across a bunch of xseries
well if that kernel is pot compiled code
it's lightning fast now the problem is
in pandas it's not always it's not
always a fast colonel trying to figure
out how to fix that so to connect it to
something fast very possible generalize
you thongs take that a step further and
now your kernels can take a little
arrays and produce other arrays so now
you can basically have Colonels arrays
taking a raise for using other arrays
and now you can map that across huge
numbers of computing that is at the
heart of a ray or in computing if you
apply a or in a computing you can get
scale they'll scale up and scale out
because it paralyzes very naturally if
you kind of think in you funks and
generalize you funks your code will be
faster long-term so here's a very simple
example in demo of how would I make a
windowed compute filter so it's a very
common expression very common need of a
bunch of data and I want to take
sub-regions of that data to produce an
output and I want to do that kind of in
a shifted way across the whole the whole
length of a vector so these little these
little bubbles here show I'm kind of
taking groups of five in this particular
case and returning a result based on
those groups of five now how would I do
that well if it's a linear filter that
actually is a fi r and scifi signal l
filter and M peak involved there's
already tools to do that if it's just a
linear filtering so the example i'm
going to show you can also just call a
function in sci-fi or numpy to do it but
what if your its nonlinear you want to
do some crazy computation or do some
crazy things that's just not possible
how do I do that well there's two
approaches basically and this sort of
show these two approaches to illustrate
how using a generalized you funk can
help you and the on the left hand side
you see this is using numba to basically
just write a nested for loop now you'd
never do a nested for loop and umpire
without getting because it's going to be
really slow but with [ __ ] it turns
out it's really fast it's just like yo
fortran code looks very similar and so
you can get you can write this code just
like this and make it really fast so
here i'm taking an input and a length of
the window and I'm looping over the
larger in the larger window excusing the
whole array I'm looping over in the
first outer loop index by K and the
inner loop is where i'm doing the
average of the five elements or the NW
elements just computing the sum divided
by
average and storing it away so I
literally put this example together in
about 15 minutes and that was including
the stride chicks effort to try to
figure out how to do that the
generalized you funk so the normal case
is easy hand-coded implementation it's
actually pretty fast but if you take
advantage of thinking about well then I
see how do I actually take a 1d array
and pretend it's a 2d array well there's
this little funny function called stride
tricks and if you don't want anything
else today this is sort of advanced
knowledge you can come and take away hey
I the author of numpy showed me this
really cool thing Freck and if i change
the strides of my array and who knows
what strides our raise your hand okay
those who don't know what strides are
strides is how numpy knows about
multiple mentions what makes it
something a two-dimensional array
because in memory it's just one linear
index of data right numpy knows about
dimensions because it has a byte offset
it knows that you go in this dimension I
just simply skip by a certain number of
bytes so that's that's how
multi-dimensional array is working on
pie it's very straightforward very
simple what that means is i canna fake a
two-dimensional array it could take my
1d array and fake a two-dimensional
array where the second dimension is is
shifted offsets right so I just take
this hundred length array and make a 98
x 3 array right which is the starting
point and then the three the length NW
windows which might be three might be 5
7 20 whatever whatever your window
length is so that's what that stride
tricks is doing and you do it by simply
copying the stride to jump into the next
dimension I just go the same number of
bytes as I go in to go into this in the
first dimension so now i have a two
dimensional array but isn't copy any
data it's just one mention of data I've
just faked numpy into thinking of the 2d
array and now I can apply a generalized
you funk and write my kernel that takes
a small window of data the colonel now
takes just this tiny little five vectors
that's the input of the colonel and do
something with them and then the when i
call the generalized you funk with this
average kernel function here in the
right hand side it's colleen and
basically the numpy machinery that does
the outer loop and all i'm implementing
for the colonel is that inner loop in
the full implementation so you can see
then compare the left hand side in the
right hand side the average colonel
that's I'm vectorizing is simply the amp
tation of the inner loop now the
generalize you funk till I sell it okay
the input is a float 8 vector
one-dimensional array that's what that
string syntax means f8 bracket colon
means it's an array and the signature is
I take an end length array and our
return of scalar the nuance here is that
to describe a scalar output you actually
have to tell it it's a array output so
you can access the element it's a little
bit of a wart I think it might have been
changed but this is a bit but I didn't
have time to test that so that's a
generalized you funk you can apply
generalized you funks it makes it really
trivially easy to take a 1d array and
provide you g you vectorize well now
compile that to machine code and if you
test these two implementations out the
full implementation hand-coded is
actually faster for smaller arrays like
100 to 200 500 elements for bigger
arrays the scalable array ordered
solution is faster and the advantage of
the generalize ugu vectorize approach is
now it can run on GPUs by target equals
GPU it can run on many cores by target
equals parallel and now I have access to
my full machine very important
understand with very simple code you can
have access to your entire machine your
full comp your full capability set
that's not a single box of course the
output is a filtered version just a
simple average other interesting things
going to skip forward because they don't
have a lot of time and show you desk
because I'm super excited to make sure
that everybody here who is thinking it
was using pi spark try to ask if you're
thinking about using pi spark tried to
ask not saying that spark won't solve
another problem for you but I'm saying
that a lot of the problems you're trying
to solve a spark right now I think are
better solve a desk obviously these are
two different systems and because of
that they have different solution spaces
and if and you can actually their cases
we can use them together to solve even
bigger problems so that's a cut it's
very exciting addition to the space to
the pie to the ecosystem now before I
say that it's important before you go
show it and go buy a bunch of machines
and try to paralyze your system use a
better algorithm improve your actual
single machine performance maybe buy a
bigger box there's a lot of thing you
know subsample your data there's a lot
of reasons to sort of not because is
harder there's more effort there's more
work even with a sweet
how to make it simpler but it still is
harder overview of tasks sewed asked is
a parallel Python computing library it's
familiar it implements and leverages
numpy and pandas ecosystems so with task
we can already do data frames because
we're using pandas to do the actual
computation and already do or a
computing or using an umpire to do the
computation we take advantage of dying
instantly as it comes online it's
flexible it's has sophisticated MSE
algorithms it builds a graph it scales
out runs resilient Leon clusters to
hundreds of machines scales down it gets
pragmatic to use even on a single laptop
with many cores it's interactive one of
the things that you can actually it's
really fun to sit on with it's in front
of a terminal and have hundreds of
machines your disposal and basically
it's as if it's a single pandas
dataframe when in reality it's sitting
across all those data are sitting across
tens and hundreds of machines so it
gives you interactive access to kind of
pandas like numpy like experiences but
on a cluster very excited about dyess it
complements the rest of anaconda we've
been working on it for four years we
were working on it it's basically
emerged as the latest innovation out of
the blaze ecosystem and it's it's
delivering on the promise we made four
years ago it fits here in a spectrum and
there's a lot of talks online and I'm
really go to detail about to ask it kind
of just want to emphasize it it's there
available for you to use you should
definitely try it out high level how it
works one of the things that's beautiful
about ask it's a very scalable solution
and it has an ecosystem of tools and we
build around it so the key part is what
you're building with desk is a
dictionary implementation of a directed
graph of tasks and those tasks can be
arbitrary Python code what if those
tasks are basically chunks of numpy
functions or chunks of pandas functions
that's how the array that's how the data
frame is implemented you basically don't
worry about the chunking that's the
collection the Adastra takes care of
that for you and you just pretend you
have a big ol array or a big ol data
frame but behind the scenes it's
creating this directed graph of tasks
now that hands off to a scheduler and
each of these are orthogonal so you can
basically take a stake and write your
own scheduler if you want if you don't
like the reference schedulers that are
come with desk you can build your own or
connect with your own fancy scheduler
capab
and take the just take the
representation of the parallel program
that das has given you in the directed
graph it's a very very powerful system
very flexible very very capable here's
just the collections you have the desk
array on which you can do numpy logic
expressions you have a desk data frame
on which you can use data frame like
expressions group buys and bout and
means and then the bag is probably the
closest thing the RTD is a desk subsumes
the concepts of the RTD and the bag is
basically a simpler python list it's
like a generic distributed list and you
can do a bunch of things with it and the
imperative is the concept of just taking
arbitrary functions and putting a
delayed in front of them and just adding
arm and using this to build up an
arbitrary expression graph you if forth
the array or the data frame doesn't
quite compute or complete the
computation you're looking for so every
kind of thing you're doing maybe you're
doing cross validation on a secular
system ultimately that becomes a machine
learning pipeline this is like a machine
learning pipeline and if you want to do
this in parallel you have a bunch of
machine learning pipelines with
different parameters and it creates a
bigger graph and that's fine you just
throw that bigger graph to desk and off
it goes and it and distribute and the
schedulers and there are three different
schedulers synchronous that's actually
just a test scheduler it's actually
don't do this in parallel just check
because parallel debugging is really
hard and make sure I'm actually doing
what I think I'm doing the threaded and
the multi-process schedulers are
intended for single node to take
advantage of all your course rapidly and
then distributed is the exciting new
scheduler that allows you to take
advantage of hundreds of machines and do
a task problem on a bunch of nodes so
the graphs themselves can be arbitrary
it shows you how you might build a graph
from a simple array expression A plus 1
times 2 raised to the third power all of
those different lines independent
parallel lines or chunks of the array
and you're operating on them
independently but they can get more
complicated than that here's an example
where you have a mean then you calculate
the standard deviation so it comes back
around and that directed graphs bit more
complicated so the schedule has to do a
little more work to make sure that the
data that needs to do another task is
available for that tab before that task
runs
and the distributed scheduler I won't go
into the details there we don't have a
lot of time but basically the idea of
this tribute schedulers have a client
machine talking to a scheduler all I
have to do is run something called D
worker on all my nodes and there's ways
to do that integrate with yarn so yarn
can fire up the D worker and every node
you can allocate the resources then you
run d scheduler on one node and that's
your a context effectively that's where
you go and then you run your expressions
the scheduler communicates out to the
workers so they do the right work the
return what its data aware data local
aware the scheduler is resilient
schedulers elastic the schedulers local
call it data local aware as long as you
read data with you have to write you
have to make sure you're reading the
data in a way that's if you just have
one node reading all the data and try to
make Basque work with that it's not
going to be parallel but if you actually
read have your work your pipeline read
data from all the nodes and there's an
HDFS library and it has three FS library
inside a distributed attributed
scheduler to make that easy for you to
show you how that's done but it's easy
to extend and keep working with on a
cluster the D cluster command actually
automates the schedule running the
scheduler in the workers and all the
nodes there's resource management
integration with yarn that's a project
called knit that's on that's part of the
desk github organization because desk is
basically ready to fly off on its own
and become its own project it now has
its own github organization called
Basque it sort of was spawn and
incubated in the blaze ecosystem and now
it's it's own desk github your
organization and that's where knit in
HDFS and the desk capabilities are
living there's also a project called
deck to what that does is it's very very
easy to spend a lot of money on Amazon
this you can with that one command spin
up tens and dozens and hundreds of nodes
on Amazon machines and put task and the
anaconda up stack on all of them and
then basically instantly have this
beautiful cluster machine ready at your
fingertips to work through Jupiter
notebook and and and load data from and
go to town if you are interested in more
robust Enterprise versions of this this
is where the pitch from continuum comes
we do have a product called on a kind of
cluster that makes this even easier and
come talk to us if you'd like this is
scale in your enterprise and connect
with parcels from cloud area
or connect with stock from a dupe or do
from hortonworks excuse me or do
integrate with your current system
there's a there's a visualization tool
that's built in so you can actually
visualize and see what's happening with
your cluster all the machines that are
running the process that are running
it's a very nice example of the bokya
visualization bouquets another fantastic
project I'm not gonna have time not to
talk about it except for this one slide
but what I'll say is the mat rockland
did a lot of work with task in an
afternoon he was able to take bouquet
and build this that shows how easy it is
used to build a working interactive web
visualization tool with bouquet today he
was not a web visualization expert Nora
JavaScript guy was able to produce this
pretty quickly so lots of examples
there's webinars online I just want to
kind of provide a little more pictures
to see how desk is a logical collection
of chunks and so you can take basically
a bunch of data that might exist in a
penalty is panas data frames what Basque
does is collect them all together so you
can operate on them as one logical data
frame and it takes care of the
distribution and the scaling you can do
very complicated things to do text data
if you just use the bag interface the
desk array you know takes little chunks
of numpy rays and makes a logical large
large scale array and then das delayed
lets you do custom workflows basically
anything you like as possible so in
conclusion base i'm here to tell you
that Python does scale and it scales
beautifully and it scales without the
JVM and it scales allowing you to take
advantage of all the great tools the
sukkot learns the innovation that's
going to continue as I look at this
conference and I see the wonderful talks
it that are here innovation is
continuing and it will continue and with
numba and ask you can get the fastest
code you need out of your machine for
the hardware you have you don't have to
turn to cuda you don't have to turn to
see you don't have turned to fortran and
you can get scale-out solution as well
you don't have to turn the JVM you don't
have to turn these other solutions now
you can use those other solutions still
Python integrates beautifully with
whatever you like so it's not that
they're off limits you can absolutely
use them but you don't have to and so
that lets you use them appropriately
when you really need them and not
because there just wasn't another
interface that Python had so that's very
exciting and please contribute to the
next stage of the journey so I said
we've landed on the moon so to speak but
we're really trying to call an
as Mars so there's a lot of work still
have to do and a lot of people can a lot
of need for people to jump in and
contribute around the num focus
ecosystem around the PI data ecosystem
or specifically around the projects that
i described so thank you very much it's
been a pleasure privileged to be here
I'll take questions
we have about five minutes for
questioning very much that was a lovely
keynote we'll take questions in one
second point of admin the speakers for
the next rooms Christian urban and Luke
could you go on to your rooms please and
get set up so we can smoothly go over
ten o'clock to the next talks so just
those speakers to leave the room please
and then get over to questions with
questions thanks very much to Travis
that's interesting overview um can you
talk a little bit about Conda Forge
because where's McKinney saying it's
like pythons a red heart moment of like
to enable enterprise-ready kind of
technologies and community driven
enterprise-level adoption of Python
could you talk a little bit but yes i'm
not sure what is all been said in that
regard so i haven't read the blog or if
you're referring to so i don't know if i
can say that so anaconda has been
Enterprise ready for a long time
actually what what's needed though is a
way to connect the enter key community
energy in a way that makes it fast to go
from community activity to enterprise
deployment and that's really what kind
of Forge i think is allowing because
effectively it's unblocking the
bottleneck of having just a few people
building kind of packages and making it
possible for an ecosystem of people to
build kind of packages around a common
build system right a common build build
core but the enterprise delivery of that
is actually a separate question you know
making that reproducible and making that
reliable and support it and indemnify
that's a separate question I don't know
that helps but it's one reason I'm
really eager about with Conda we always
we made it open source you made a bsd
license precisely to let people build
Conda packages however they like but
it's really important to have a kind of
a uniform way to do it so that you don't
have all this fracturing that's going on
currently in the Python ecosystem for
binaries another question yeah Stephen
can you say a bit about the relationship
between data fabric and
arrow and feather yeah data fri works a
generalization of arrow i love arrow the
idea but it's like a very small piece of
the general concept that i'm pursuing
the data fabric so you can imagine arrow
provides like one kind of data shape or
maybe a family of data shapes so it's
good idea but i just want to make it
more general i realize you just talked
to us about giving us incredibly precise
tools with desk and so on but are there
any plans to overlay sequel over the top
yes so that's actually a blaze fits in
so blazed already can you can basically
transformed a sequel on top but maybe
you're looking for is there a sequel
translation to a basque engine there
aren't current plans for that you could
certainly build an Impala like thing on
top of desk right we are instead using
blaze as kind of the interface because a
lot of people especially for advanced
analytics who were targeting it would
prefer to write Python expressions there
are there people who would love to write
sequel as well but they sort of already
have tools for that they can run sequel
on top of hive they can run sequel on
top of spark the problem is I guess Ben
do want a faster and maybe dascon phase
can be faster it's good idea I think
that's sort of a down the road road map
piece for us if others would like to
take that on I think that's an awesome
project a sequel interface on top of
desk would be beautiful
you mentioned briefly about installing
parcel for clouded and hotter bus
cluster yes horn works is called stacks
they're not called parcels but yes so we
have parcels available for anaconda so
Anaconda comes in a parcel it's really a
static one of the problems with parcels
there's sort of a static deployment many
people like that with the tools we have
an entourage offer and you can create
parcels quickly oh sorry so yeah that's
part of our enterprise now there is a
free parcel you can get today but that
is updated it's not very I'm not updated
that often I think we wrap up there I
promise you over to be around I'll be
around absolutely
you